- Dan.
- Yeah.
This is the biggest pumpkin.
Oh, no, don't say that.
You'll do well
to miss this one.
Oh, I'm gonna miss it
now that you've said that.
Pull.
( theme music playing )
- Hello, I 'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
Welcome
to "The Super Slow Show."
Dan, I've seen you fire
a lot of weapons in our time.
Yeah, I've fired everything
you can fire,
apart from, like,
a rocket launcher
or guided missile, I think.
- One day.
- One day, maybe.
Thing is I've only ever
seen you hit a stationary
target.
You're pretty good,
but how about we get some
moving targets on the go?
I mean, for example,
fruit and plates and that.
I've never seen
a pumpkin move before.
Thankfully, we have the use
of our lovely classic catapult.
So I'm going
to load everything
into this bucket
and whatever fits, flies.
How about that?
Yeah. Again,
very unconventional.
Yeah, most people
would use a clay pigeon,
but we're going to use
anything we want.
What do you wanna shoot
first, pumpkin?
Yeah, I'll get my eye
on something big.
Hone it in.
We'll get down to smaller?
- All right.
- I'll get the pumpkin.
We're gonna shoot this at a
thousand frames a second in 4K,
one from behind,
one from over there.
Won't be fast enough
to see the round,
but it will be fast enough
to see this thing break apart.
Ready? And pull!
( bleep )
Pull!
Miles away.
Pull.
No, missed it completely.
This is the biggest pumpkin.
Oh, no, don't say that.
You'll do well
to miss this one.
Oh, I'm gonna miss it,
now you've said that.
Pull.
( bleep )
- ( Gav cackling )
- ( bleep )
Yo, a completely different
arc again.
How is it different?
'Cause the other one went,
like, twice as far.
So it turns out
I've actually hit it
with most of the buckshot.
Right in the middle, but,
because it's a pumpkin,
the buckshot goes in
and nothing happens to it.
- Oh.
- So it doesn't burst
the buckshot.
So the buckshot
doesn't burst it.
So you mean, like,
a slug or something?
I think we need to change
what we're hitting.
We need to lob
something different.
So we're thinking a pumpkin
is just a bad target for this,
considering it just absorbs
and keeps going. It's solid.
This is a balloon of paint,
though,
not as solid.
Pull!
- Oh!
- Whoa.
- You've got it.
- Yeah.
A new balloon.
Okay.
All right, pull.
Oh! That one exploded.
It burst completely,
didn't it?
That was a great shot.
Cheers.
Let's go watch it back.
Dan:
Look at it jiggling
in the air like that.
- Do you see that?
- Yeah.
Dan:
You see the wad go
underneath it?
Gav: Yeah, that's actually
the only bit you see, really.
Yeah, it is.
You can't see the buckshot.
It's so small.
Balloon burst nicely,
though.
- ( together ) Gory.
- Yeah, that was...
- Jinx. Eh...
- Oh, damn it.
Buy you a Coke.
Nah.
Dan:
It's actually like a robotic
arm watching it, isn't it?
Gav:
So you got a lock on.
Oh, that was good,
good leading on it.
Wow. You can see you definitely
fired in front of it
on that shot.
You have to, yeah, 'cause it's
moving actually quite fast.
You know, it just bursts
and spreads everywhere.
If someone stood below that,
they would be
absolutely showered.
Will you trust me enough
to stand under it
while I'm shooting it?
- No, I don't think
I'd risk it.
- No? No?
Just in case.
- You see the wad
go into it there?
- Gav: Yeah.
It's like the thing
that pushes
the buckshot forwards.
Next up I'm going to go
for some paint-filled vases.
Really gonna get it
nice and full.
Yeah, get it.
You ready, Dan?
Uh, I'm gonna try
and hit something
out of the, like,
ten things that
are in there for sure.
Two shots?
- Two shots.
- All right.
Pull!
Damn, that's quick.
Can't tell if I hit
anything again.
I think you did.
I think you clipped
the neck of one of them.
Okay.
Dan: Did I hit it?
I think you hit the neck
of the green one, that low one.
- What?
- Good call.
Gav: Some of the buckshot
just hit the loose paint.
Look at that.
I think that was
your first shot.
It was. I don't think
I managed to hit anything
with the second shot
'cause I was actually aiming
much too high.
- Did you fire both, though?
- I did.
I think I fired
too late, though.
- Oh, there it is.
- Oh, I did it!
I got it!
So it was, like, an inch
from the ground, but you got it.
- It counts, right?
- Oh, we've gotta count it.
- It counts.
- Yeah.
The pot didn't know
the floor was coming up.
- Yeah.
- Pot's just like,
"What happened?"
That's fair.
That was about this far
from the floor, though,
to be fair, you know.
Well, it's a lovely
amount of carnage.
- Very colorful as well.
- Very pretty, yeah.
I can't tell what's a plate
or what's a pumpkin.
I think we should maybe set up
a business,
where instead of having
clay pigeons,
you have just
anything you want.
Vases with paint.
- TVs.
- Exactly.
And you don't really need
to move it
because everything
acts different.
We had some stuff land here,
some stuff land here,
go high, go low.
- So it's, like, challenging
and satisfying.
- Yeah.
Well, thank you
for watching that video.
Feel free to subscribe
to The Slow Mo Guys,
and we'll see you
in the next episode
of "The Super Slow Show."
( rock music playing )
Hey, everyone.
Be sure to click
right over there
and stay connected
with the show
as we're posting
new videos almost daily,
but for right now,
go check out more episodes
in this general region
over here somewhere,
I think.
Just--
There? Yeah.
Maybe...
there?
Yeah.